Key columns make it possible to connect the fact and dimension tables together.
Our grocery store database has
both a product dimension table and the aforementioned sales transaction fact table.
For us to be able to use all the details on the product dimension.
We need the fact table to have a key column with
values that align with our dimension tables keys as well.
Let's use the product key for Granny Smith apples to better understand this.
Customers by Granny Smith apples multiple times a day.
Our sales transaction table we'll need to list Granny Smith apples
every time to be able to connect to the product table with that key.
But the product table only list Granny Smith apples once.
If for some reason the Granny Smith apples were listed in
the product dimension more than once with the same product key,
this wouldn't really work.
For the same reason you would be very
confused if you went to the store to buy Granny Smith apples,
and discovered there were two unique Granny Smith apple
available in separate bins with no additional information or context.
The example we just walked through helps to demonstrate why
key columns can have many values with our facts,
but just one value on the dimension table
which we refer to as a one-to-many relationship.
Just like you'd be confused about which Granny Smith apple you should pick,
your data model won't understand which of
the two identical products to use even
if the additional columns it's connected to are different.
Whenever a fact key ties exactly with
a corresponding dimension key we refer to this as relational integrity.
Something you will want to ensure is in place every time that you build a data model.
Simply put, relational integrity just means that the fact tables
key can correctly and completely aligned with the dimension table keys.
You'll run into some interesting problems if you
have either a wrong key or a missing key.
Let's start with the wrong key.
If you have the wrong key all of your transactions will be accounted for,
but your report will provide the wrong information.
This could lead to decisions being made on incorrect data.
For example, if Granny Smith apples were miscoded with the artichoke code
on the fact table the report would show a sudden surge in artichoke sales,
and the manager might order a high volume of artichokes that's
has just no demand based on this incorrect information.
Any transactions that have no corresponding key for
a given dimension will basically be
orphaned when you try to summarize that data by dimension.
Again, if in this instance the Granny Smith code was not miscoded but just missing.
That would mean that sales for Granny Smith
could not be included in any sub total sales for fruit,
and instead it's going to show up where no product dimension filters are in place.
If you create a table by
grocery store product type you'll see all the working keys group correctly,
but Granny Smith will be on its lonesome in this awkward blank category.
There's one more thing that you will want to keep in mind when it comes to key columns.
Fact, and dimension keys must match exactly to facilitate relational integrity,
keys can use a combination of numbers, letters,
or symbols to create a unique value so much as
the corresponding values between both tables align exactly.
For the example that we've used so far this 10,001 pipe Granny Smith will work well,
but any mismatch between one key column and the other will cause trouble.
I'll give you a few examples.
Here's a few that won't work,
having the same number and pipe symbol but different
versions of the word Granny Smith won't result in a working key,
nor will to text strings where one has a space but they're otherwise identical.
Nor will the same number and text,
but with different symbols.
You get where I'm going with this.
Close but no cigar doesn't work with keys.
Always be precise and look for
these small discrepancies if you're running into key issues.